quand on passe derrière l'orateur comme
le jeune frère qui était là tout à
l'heure qui raconte son expérience et je
sais qu'il ya eu avant moi il ya eu au
moins six orateurs qui sont passés
chacun est venu avec une expérience
chacun à raconter une expérience inédite
il n'est pas évident pour nous tuer l'on
appelait d'avoir grand chose à dire là
je suis disposé tout de même à partager
ma petite expérience et mon petit
parcours d'artiste avec vous et avec
fierté en plus alors je vais commencer
par dire là vous voyez une photo où il
ya de sourire pour arriver à ces
sourires ce n'était pas gagné d'avancé
on écrit en français tout simplement
c'était pas évident moi je dirais que ce
n'était pas gagné d'avancé
c'était très dur c'était de même
compliqué
magic system aujourd'hui je crois que
notre histoire tous les ivoiriens
la connaissent par des petits interview
que nous avons accordé par ci par là du
passage des mercis agnès crédit qui nous
a accordé notre première interview en
tant qu'artiste et comme je le disais
pour arriver à là il a fallu cravacher
parce que se battre
j'ai trop répété le mot se battre dans
mes chansons il a fallu s'armer
de beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup du courage
or âgées c'est fou quand vous
applaudissez mais pour vous dit quelque
chose c'est la photo de laquelle je suis
le plus fier
[Applaudissements]
quand ils m'ont présenté un diaporama et
où j'ai dit mais il ya une photo qui
manquent
ça c'est l'illustration de la galère
qu'ils peuvent vivre quelqu'un cette
photo mes propres enfants ont réfugiés
d'admettre que c'était leur papa je le
redis se voir papa c'est pourquoi vous
devez être fiers de votre maman parce
que c'est pas évident
[Applaudissements]
ben là moi je me mets à la place de ma
femme
comment est-ce qu'on peut inspirer l
avenir avec mais hélas kumm l'amour à
des réseaux qui miaule avait raison
jusqu'aujourd'hui on ne m'a pas dit
pourquoi elle m'a suivi dans ces moments
là une chose est sûre elle a été un
pilier de mon ascension parce que dans
ces moments quand on traverse un moment
difficile
on a besoin de quelqu'un à côté de choix
pour donner foi vous donner espoir qui
s'appuie aller un jour je suis fier
d'eux dit qu'elle était parmi les plus
belles femmes de ma commune et c'est moi
qu'elle a choisi la nature n'était pas
content moi c'est le temps qui est en
cours du mois
[Applaudissements]
mais après on est passé à autre chose
il ya beaucoup de personnes sur les
réseaux sociaux
c'est la photo je sais que dans le cadre
des tracts et je m'attaquais on balance
un fourre tout mais ils savent pas que
quand il balance la photo moi ça me
remplit de fierté parce que pouvoir
aller chercher la photo de 1998 97 pour
la publier alors que j'ai des photos
l'essence avait dit que le changement un
tort aujourd'hui et hier est tellement
radical qui a publié une photo de moi
aujourd'hui c'est là une défaite pour
mes détracteurs donc il faut à l'arrière
pour publier celle là bas on est passé à
autre chose je veux vous dire que il ne
faut jamais désespérer dans la vie il
faut s'armer de certaines valeurs
pour se donner les moyens il faut se
définir d'abord les critères qui peuvent
nous permettre d'avancer
moi je parle de la persévérance de la
détermination et du leadership la
persévérance on vient d'un nouveau où on
parlait de trois repas par jour à la
télé tout mais chez nous c'est ainsi que
en double où on appelait la mort subite
manger à 16h et attendre le lendemain
pour le futur et pas et quand vous êtes
dans ce genre du quartier vous est la
risée de tout le monde vous avez arrêté
les études au détriment du ou ailleurs
que vous faites sans même inspiré qui un
jour vous allez être artiste
les moqueries envoya des parents venus
se plaindre à nous parce qu on draguait
leur fille je veux plus
je vois rôder autour de ma fille parce
que les conditions dans lesquelles nous
étions les la suivait pas quelqu'un de
pouvoir espérer qu'un jour ça puisse
aller et nous on avait ce défi on devait
relever ce défi on devait montrer que
c'est impossible mais là où on souffre
le plus c'est quand nos amis
yodé siro espoir 2000 et tout ça entre
en studio
il faut sortir des albums qui font des
centaines de milliers de pièces vendues
et que nous ne sommes toujours dans le
même engouement pour tout le monde nous
voyait avec faire le noyau les mots
kerry se multiplient les railleries
il ya tout c'est à dire tout est réuni
pour vous décourager
là ce que je veux dire aux jeunes qui
sont là aujourd'hui
les mots kerry la calomnie la médisance
tout ce qu'on peut dire de vous braves
des éléments catalyseurs des éléments
qui vous permet de vous surpasser pour
aller même au delà de vos objectifs
parce que quand les gens ont commencé à
dire je dérangeante et à ses coteaux qu
elles se prennent les mellino chanter je
pensais pas encore nous ont fait sortir
un album on vend 7000 cassette
l'anecdote c'est que quand on signait le
comtat on nous a dit c'est après 2004
qu'on va vous payer
nous on a fait cette mêlée donc on va
voir le producteur pour voir si on peut
pas avoir un peu une audition continue
on va lui rembourser les 3 de
médicaments
il fallait persévérer
il fallait quand on a fait premier gaou
on est allé voir le même producteur ils
nous ont dit nous on est pas produit que
les artistes qui peut vendre au moins
10000 vous sortez dans l'album qui s'est
vendu à 7 millions attendez qu'on
produise n'avait de groupe a produit et
même pour aller terminer l'album c'est
le fit ou quartier excusez-moi j'ai
serré
[Applaudissements]
j'avais promis à mon équipe que j'allais
retenir mes émotions mer donc je disais
qu'au quartier même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
je disais que même pour aller en studio
on était obligés d'aller voir des filles
qui transfère au quartier mais le franc
500 cotisants nous donne pour aller en
studio je vais pas la course de
l'histoire du premier gaou parce que on
a un livre qui va sortir qui va parler
de 20 ans des magic system vous aurez
l'occasion de voir tout le chemin qui a
été tracé quand je préparais mon
intervention
mes équipes m'ont laissé en tant qu' il
fallait parler 15 minutes jeudi à les
équipes je peux pas le juger mon
histoire en 15 minutes
si je veux partager vraiment mes
expériences
je ne peux pas après on m'envoyait un
lien qu'on va préparer une intervention
comme à jeudi mais on ne peut pas me
dire comment raconter ma propre histoire
parce que préparer une intervention
savez dit c'est rédigé et on sait tous
que quand on rédige ont ce don le
pouvoir des rails et des mentions alors
que mon histoire il n'ya rien à rayer
dans mon histoire je dois la raconter
comme elle est donc je parlais de
persévérance je disais que d'avoir vie
il peut avoir des éléments qui vous
amène à vous démoraliser à vous
déconcentrer pour aller devant une
petite anecdote en 1997
nous sommes invités pour une tournée
d'une marque de cigarettes hama au stade
municipal du mans on n'avait pas encore
sorti premier gaou
on avait sorti une note album qui avait
vendu 7 millions et à 2 heures du matin
on t'a pas ma chambre je me réveille
je demande s'il ya un problème on me dit
oui il ya un problème il ya un artiste
qui à côté je ne vous citerai pas le nom
ici je suis pas venu pour ça y'a un
artiste qui a coûté qui allait pas que
vendeur que non ils te la climatisation
de sa chambre d'école
on veut que tu pars là-bas élus
l'avenida chant et c'est ce qu'on a fait
dans la nuit j'ai pris mon petit sac
dans nos membres
je suis sorti je suis allé dans le champ
et je me suis couché
je dis ce que je viens de vivre sa maman
elle soit à baisser les bras
soit continuer pas pour qu'un jour on
déplace de lyon pour que je prenne sa
place le soir ça m'a même à conduire
pour dire que tous les facteurs négatifs
de la vie ne doit pas forcément agir sur
l'avenir ou sur les projets de quelqu'un
ça devait plutôt être un élément qui
tonnent la force qui motive donc la
persévérance admise et pour passer à
cela il faut avoir de la détermination
on peut être persévérant et allez vous
lit sans avoir réalisé quelque chose
s'il n'est pas déterminée la
détermination est de mise mais moi
j'étais avec mes 3 beaucoup d'entre vous
sont ceux qui sur les réseaux sociaux ou
dans leurs pensées intérieures 10 mais
lui c'est lui qu'on voit toujours pour
qu'on ne voit pas les autres salut qui
bouffent tout l'agent du groupe
pourquoi ça lui qui atteint pourquoi ça
l'uqat un nom
dès le début quand on a formé le groupe
j'ai dit j'ai agi en tant que grand
frère et sur le plus âgé le deuxième
j'ai goûté en plus et moi il ya sept
mois
je suis né à mars il est né en octobre
et ça on peut pas rattraper ça j'ai dit
moi je suis voir grand faire si vous
voulez qu'on sait pas s'il ya quelque
chose qui n'a fait vingt ensemble ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il n'y a pas de moment
où il ya eu des altercations des moments
où on s'insulte ans et plus ça c'est
faux mais la plus belle union c'est
l'union où on peut se battre et je leur
ai parlé après pas de se séparer et moi
en tant que grand frein j'avais cette
mission j'entends des gens dire c'est
lui qui bouffent tout l'argent ce qui
m'amène encore à vous raconter une
anecdote en 2002 quand nous arrivons en
france virgin music heures de contacter
individuellement ils me disent on a
besoin de toi pour continuer est ce que
vous savez la prime à la signature d'un
contrat avec une major je ne vous dis
pas mais au moins satisfaits qui t'aime
mon goût et à l'époque je n'avais que
627 1000 simon prend dans la bio
ils se croient les proposent ou tu t'es
les gars je ne voudrais pas le montant
du savant
t'es pas lâcher la proposition et
j'arrive à dire aux gens j'ai décidé
avec eux de créer de famille de
continuer je peux pas les laisser ou de
l'argent alors comment voulez vous que
je refuse de l'argent pour rester avec
eux et plus tard voulu apprendre sud et
argent pourquoi si je voulais le faire
le raccourci est elle en 2002 j'ai
devenir millionnaire en dix minutes de
conversation j'ai dit non
il ya des valeurs qu'il faut pas trahir
l'argent c'est bon mais la valeur morale
n'a pas de prix et il fallait garder
cette valeur parce que pour moi là je
parle de la détermination qui vont
forcément l'arménie vers le leadership
puisque c'est là que je veux en venir
pour dit que le leadership le leader
c'est pas le chef c'est le politicien
qui vont dénoncer lui le chef
le leader c'est celui qui fédère autour
de lui
celui qui a une vision qui dépasse 1
vision permet d'un groupe avec le leader
on lundi avec le patron ou le chef on lé
soin des autres
magic system j'ai essayé d'être le grand
frère est demandé m mon leadership au
profit du groupe
si on veut vérifier ici au contrôle des
diplômés dans cette salle si on veut
compter les diplômés j'ai dit [ __ ] ce
que j'essaierai avant-dernier ou même
dernier parce que je n'ai pas le niveau
d'étude que certains quoi moi j'ai
arrêté au collège c'est les aléas de la
vie qui m'ont forgé à être là
aujourd'hui et a parlé à des gens c'est
par la première conférence que je tiens
à parler à des gens je me suis dit dieu
la nature m'a fait le plaisir de
m'accompagner
je veux partager ça avec les gens j'ai
une image c'est la force de pouvoir
aider rien que par le nom de mon groupe
pourquoi ne pas aider et en 2008 gêné si
gêné si le festival des musiques
urbaines d'anoumabo vous permettre à nos
membres
je vois pas ce qu'elle nous quand on
était petit notre rêve c'était de voir
alpha blondy il n'est pas dit venez
chanter venez passer devant le mambo un
jour c'était la drève et aujourd'hui
nous les magic system le p tit qui
aliment bosson reims et multiplie par
dix et on s'est dit il faut que chaque
année on parties chantées
mais si on va chanter on ne va pas la
faire danser après il retouche dans les
mêmes conditions
construisons des écoles et les habitants
des hôpitaux allons chercher des
partenaires qui vont nous aider à le
faire on a cherché des partenaires
personnes accueillies par leurs projets
on s'est dit c'est toujours les mêmes
artistes créent des choses moi j'ai dit
je veux construire l'école parlement
bout les gens disent c'est de la blague
alors je consacre les droits d'auteur de
l'année 2008
je prends le risque de faire la pose de
la première pierre
devant le ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui à l'époque était gilbert
bleu lainé et j'ai dit au ministre
l'année prochaine je vais livrer cette
école je prends mes droits d'auteur et
je considère cette école c'est rare le
temps ont permis de construire l'école
est de donner de la crédibilité au
projet que nous faisons aujourd'hui il
ya des partenaires qui viennent nous
aider à construire des écoles qui
viennent nous aider à réaliser
des implants situe à pour le bien-être
des populations
et c'est tout à notre honneur
juste pour dire que la vie que nous
vivons aujourd'hui ce n'est pas de dire
aux gens de ne pas nous oublier
c'est pas cette vie là tout ce que nous
faisons aujourd'hui c'est pas de la
promotion c qui a écrit devant vous
immortel
personne ne peut prétendre être immortel
dans la vie non on peut pas de lui-même
le seigneur ne l'a pas été personne ne
peut prétendre être jésus même est mort
est partie et r evenus mais nous on va
partir on peut parler venir et donc
c'est les oeuvres que nous posons les
actions que nous posons qui nous
rendront immortel ce sont ces actions là
qui doivent être immortel et non alors
il faudrait que la leçon de magic system
puisse encourager sur parmi vous qui
avait envie de baisser les bras
dites-vous toujours car baissant le prix
du main et hôpital programmé pour être
le jour où un nouvel sortie du tunnel ne
baisse jamais les bras
croyez en vos rêves à réaliser les
projets qui pourront rester immortel
car immortel c'est pas physique immortel
c'est dans ce qu'on fait avant de partir
je voulais murphy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
es tu j'ai fais quoi dynamo
non
[Musique]